hi there so um I just wanted to give the
few quick thoughts about the changes to
the Europe's submission process this
year as opposed to last year they've
announced this on the website on Twitter
with the video and so on and I thought I
might share some thoughts on that and
maybe some of you haven't heard yet in
case you're planning to submit or
thinking about it
so desk rejections it ACS area chairs
have the ability to desk reject papers
that they feel strongly are not going to
be passable to the reviewers they did an
experiment last year where the ACS were
simply supposed to mark submissions that
they would desk reject and it turned out
ACS aren't very good at estimating which
submissions are going to be rejected by
the reviewers that might be because
there wasn't really anything at stake
because it was just kind of uh let's see
how this works but it is definitely a
move to reduce the number of submissions
because the field is exploding and we
lack reviewing power reviewing people so
this is a move to reduce the number of
people that have to review something
because there will be fewer fewer papers
I don't know if this increases the
quality overall if your paper gets desk
rejected there's usually like some
obvious reason for it why an AC decided
it's not worth it
they probably haven't read it in depth
but there there might be some kind of
overall structural issue that or like
the introduction has many typos or you
know that like look for the obvious
things even though your work might be
good right right second all authors of a
paper have to be able to review if asked
to do so and again this is
this kind of reviewing crisis I have
mixed feelings about this like I really
think this is a move in the wrong
direction it will increase the number of
authors because a lot of people have
been kind of freeriding in that they're
submitting papers but they aren't
reviewing other papers even though they
would be competent researchers simply
because reviewing doesn't get you
anything so there's no incentive to do
reviews maybe you can say you're a
reviewer but then there's every
incentive to do bad reviews like
two-line reviews where the first line
says you should have compared to my
paper reject like you with your
reviewer like this in any case like a
lot of times and this hits for example
like universities where you maybe work
with a master student and the master
student does some of the pre-processing
of the data and right and they don't
really have a clue about the machine
learning but they still contribute it so
why shouldn't they be an author on the
paper they might even have been have
written that section about the data
pre-processing and now they're asked to
review entire papers about topics where
they're not really familiar with or you
have some outside collaborators or you
know that there's so many so many things
wrong I think this attracts the wrong
kind of people and by forcing people to
do it you encourage even more like all
these reviewers that would not have
reviewed what will happen is they will
give shitty reviews and you will have
even worse quality of reviews as a
result I think this is the wrong move to
reduce the number of load per reviewer
I'd rather see abolish peer review
completely in computer science in
machine learning at least that's my
opinion but that might be a video for
another time I have plans how to replace
it another time resubmissions have to be
clearly marked so if your paper is a
resubmission of like if you had already
submitted it in the last 12 months it's
been rejected you have to say it is a
resubmission and
changes you made to the paper again with
with a with a peer-review process that
actually works this would make a lot of
sense you can say well it got rejected
last time and here is how I corrected
for what the reviewers criticized but
with review quality right now I mean
most of the papers what are they gonna
say it got rejected for nefarious
reasons because the reviewer had a bowel
movement that morning and I didn't
really change much so you encourage
people to kind of blow out of proportion
the changes they're made and put a lot
of additional unnecessary work on to
papers that would actually be already
fine right so this all of these things
that they'll just they are they're
forcing people to do things and then the
incentives of what we want aren't
aligned with what we give right so what
you'll end up with is lower quality ؞
reviews and lower quality work so the
next two points are of a different
nature the first one though I thought
that would probably I mean even if the
AC's aren't perfect you know that that's
a bit I like that the fourth point and
the fifth point are a bit different the
fourth point is there is a new section
in CMT apparently where you have to
describe the broader societal impact and
ethics around your work like how will
your work influence society what are
positives and negatives ethical outcomes
how can it be used and this is targeted
towards things like let's say facial
recognition if you develop a new facial
recognition algorithm you may be able to
argue well this could be better used to
identify you know um victims in a big
crowd you know there's a mass riot or
something and then you don't know who
was there is my relative one of the
people in the mass right that gets
stomped on
or you can also say this potentially
helps a dictatorial state to govern
their people because they cannot
recognize everyone for most papers it
will be a bit shaky like if your third
order optimization algorithm that she
used a slightly better convergence rate
I'm not sure what's here but what what I
feel is that this this is it's dumb in a
way because this just means more work
right basically now you have to
demonstrate and yeah it says you just
should discuss positive and negative
aspects but in essence everyone will be
demonstrating virtue signaling how good
their work will be for society and what
good can be done and maybe a bit of bad
but that can be mitigated right and and
it just pushes it into a more PR world
so it goes from the science world into a
more PR world it means extra work and
who are the people that can afford to do
extra work it's mostly the big companies
right they can just put an additional
team member on that maybe even do
additional experiments to show the
societal impact of the work and who will
lose out or probably small universities
independent researchers and so on that
don't have that that capacity that
simply do their research right because
it's an interesting research question
and for almost every single thing in the
world that has an application it will
have good and bad applications so yeah
mixed feelings so fifth is you are now
supposed if your paper gets accepted to
make a video about it and upload the
poster basically link to the poster that
you would use and also link to slides
that you would give their talk with this
is to make it more accessible to people
people that are not at the conference
which again I have mixed feelings about
again it pushes it into this more PR
round
right talks are already live-streamed
most of them are for most of the large
conferences and I feel it just gets
people one step more away from the
actual paper like it's very so it allows
people to grandstand and in PR up even
more of their work because even people
who don't attend the conference now
they're not going to read the paper just
gonna watch the video right and in the
video you can always leave away those
you know things that you would have to
like that a reviewer makes you put in
the paper right and in the video you can
over voice things camera ready
no one reviews the video you can say
whatever you want so it's it's just
where before if you didn't attend the
conference I think many people actually
did read the paper watched talks where
people could ask questions and now it's
it's just one more PR thing and again
who has time energy and money to really
invest a lot into this it's mainly large
companies right if you're small and
you're time-bound
and so on you might not have equipment
or time to do that I am NOT for hire to
do your videos just saying I don't have
time to make these videos really as you
can see in the stellar quality I think
there's a bright glare right here so
that was it for my opinions on this and
I wish you nice day bye